Thanks guys
for coming and thank you
to everyone on live stream.
I can't see you but you look great.
Um,
my name is parallel Campos and I am the
PMM for Google doodles here at Google.
Um,
and we're here.
Hopefully everyone is in the room and
everyone on live stream are here for one
reason, a very good reason. Oh really
awesome reason. Um, and dear to my heart,
we will be launching a Google doodle for
settling back in Bosnia on October 17.
We're super excited.
This has been a huge labor of love
and it has also been a really great
collaboration with her family.
They keep nes specifically
Susan [inaudible] who will
be joining us here in one
moment. Suzette is a sister,
older sister of Santa Ana.
She was also a band mate incident idols.
He knows I'm a pretty cool
drummer if I do say so myself.
And we're going to sit down and have
an awesome chat about the life and the
legacy of Selena as well as how they
felt about the process of the doodle.
So Suzette,
welcome in.
Okay.
Hi.
Thank you so much for coming. I'm not
texting anyone. Don't be, don't worry.
I'm just going to pull up the
questions here. So, um, yeah.
And then there's also a lot of people
that you can't see, but if you,
I don't even know where we waved to,
like maybe have a,
I don't know if we're cool. Um,
all those people in TV land. Yeah.
So we're just gonna start off talking
about like life, um, in, in the band.
And I was going to be asking
questions just so everybody knows.
We'll do about 30 minutes of
just my questions. I know,
I know.
I know you're probably like,
I don't know if he can talk that long
parallel. I don't know if you're able to.
Um, but, uh, after those 30 minutes
I'll open it up for questions. Um, are,
I don't know if we're able to take from
the live stream. Yes we are. No. Okay. No,
that's fine. But if anybody
in the room has any questions,
feel free so I won't hog up
all the time. Cool. So Suzanne,
we're going to start off with,
tell us about the early days.
How did you guys first respond to
the idea of forming a family band?
And you were also all really,
really young.
So like what did your friends at school
thing that you remember that part of the
movie was like, I'll still play drums.
Yeah, I remember every part though.
You say that it's about you,
but yes,
you know, a lot of people I
get asset quite often. Um,
this kind of just happened
by chance. I mean, um,
my father had worked for Dow chemical
for over 13 years as gene was also,
you know, at one point he didn't want
that nine to five job anymore. So he,
him and a friend decided to open up a
Mexican restaurant and it was around in
the 80s.
Marlo,
some of Y'all might've been born around
in the 80 [inaudible] but it was run in
the 80s. And, um, long story short,
it was when the oil boom happened
and all that. Um, and we,
it was open for not even six months,
so we lost it at, around that time. Um,
[inaudible] my dad was teaching a
how to play the bass and then Selena,
of course,
he was the youngest and you know,
the young ones always fill
the need for attention.
So she just started humming something
and my father picked up on it and he was
like, wait a minute. Um, so
that's Kinda how it started.
It's a little bit of everything is
how it just kind of flowed into how we
actually started performing at different
parties and things like that. Um,
once Selena,
he realized it [inaudible] you know,
had the capability of holding the tune
at such an early age. Um, she was,
I think like around six,
um,
my cousin had been living with this
for my mother's side and he ended up,
he was supposed to play the drums and so
he ended up going back upstate to stay
with his father. And so lord behold
there was a pair of brand new jobs.
I'm the only kid that,
yeah, you're going to
play drums. I was like,
wait a minute,
girl.
And I really said that girls don't play
drums because at the time, you know,
the only female drummer that was
really well known when she was young,
she sure a lot of gum shield.
He is. Um, and you know,
she was the only one. And I remember
thinking, well, surely he plays dumb.
Who's the high? Like, you know
what I mean? So, um, that's how we,
I started playing in and then shortly
after that, after we started, you know,
performing as a family band,
um,
just like for a little
parties and things like that.
Whenever my dad would have friends
over or some of our friends over,
he'd asked for us to play and we
play like three or four songs.
It seemed forever for us.
Right.
And then the restaurant ended up closing
and we actually used to perform at the
restaurant, right? Yeah. Like on Fridays
and Saturdays. What was that like?
Uh, it was cool, but it wasn't
cool. And then you can see your people
that you go to school with. Right.
You're embarrassed
the thing. But it really was a
blessing in disguise because when,
when my father, when the
whole, we lost the restaurant,
we literally lost everything.
Like everything we, the house,
um, my parents really invested everything
into that house, into that restaurant.
So,
um,
the only thing that we
really knew was music.
And so we started playing little gigs
here and there and make three, four, $500,
and we'll woo. Um, and
next thing, you know, yeah,
we'll get to that farmer. Definitely.
Yeah. I'm about to ask you for that.
Don't worry. That's really how it started.
And it was just kind of like, yeah,
also a labor of love from all
of us, you know, um, we're,
we're struggling as a family and so what
other families do we come together and
do what we gotta do.
Right. That's not true.
Um,
so actually,
so we were talking about like how it is
incredible a thing to like come together
as a family and to produce this amazing
thing and just so happened that all of
you are super talented. So that's,
that's a definitely. Plus. Um,
but what were like the pros
and the cons of being in it,
because this idea of like being in a
band and maybe like you get your friends
together,
that's one thing.
But like being in a band with
your family I think is another.
So what would you say were like the pros
of that when we're also the kinds of
grass, so it Latino families. So
that's true. I wasn't gonna say it,
but you said it poorly feisty.
Yeah.
They're with budding heads and everything.
But I think one thing that really helped
keep us United is that my father and my
mother always treated each of us
equally. There is none of this like, oh,
Celine is in the front, you know, she gets
this, or I play drums. I do keep the beat
produces, you know? No, nobody had it.
Ego trip. And I think that that's one
of the things that really, uh, kept, uh,
the unity of our, our
family. And we also knew,
each one of us knew our role model.
And I kind of always like to explain the
kind of like a, I like a football team.
Quarterback knows what he's gotta do you
know the why you have the receiver and
the coach. My Dad was a coach,
right? My Dad was our manager. Um,
we let him take care of that part and,
and we did our part and I think that
that's one of the reasons why our band was
very successful. Right, right.
Well, to keep the metaphor going, you
are probably the best team that's ever,
you know, is this it
in Martinique Imo. Um,
okay. So I'd be next is you talk
about, you know, the early beginnings,
but like what is the one moment,
if you,
if you remember a moment or like when do
you actually know that you guys made it?
Like this feeling of like, oh
my gosh, this is actually right.
Like, we, we did it, um, to be
honest with you, but a lot like,
I don't even think like the data,
even when my sister passed, you know,
you don't really realize what you're
doing when you, when you're doing it,
you know. Yeah. Clearly you see your, your
contracts are being sold out. You know,
you're like, oh yeah, even at,
even at to that point where we were at
in your career right before Selena passed
it was kind of like, oh my God, I
hope we have people. Right. You know,
and I hope people show up because you
know, as an artist you never really know.
You know, you do, you do your thing,
you serve it up basically and you people
like it, they like it. If they don't,
they don't.
So I mean I think like that one scene
in the movie where everybody freaks out
cause you hear your music
on the radio, you know, we
thought, oh my God, we hit it.
Yeah, music's playing on the radio. But
guess what,
it's not like that.
Just because your music is being played
on the radio doesn't mean that the
teaching is coming in. Right, right.
It's the fact that, you know, it takes,
it's a process and this process
took about four or five,
six years before we actually
started getting known.
So it's not a quick process. A lot of
artists think that it is and it's not.
We definitely did our time playing in
small little venues for like, I remember
we used to play for like we'd, you
know, we'd go for the door, you know,
percentage of the door or
whatever. And um, you know,
we've got like 25 would show up
and we buy. Okay, so we're not,
we're just going to pack up, right.
What are you gonna Leave? Right?
And then my dad's like, nope, what
do you mean? No? You're like, well,
you have to take this like it's
practice, but just go play. Right.
These 25 people, they're going to go,
they're going to have a great time.
They're going to turn around and
bring more people next time we come.
And that was literally the God
honest truth, how it happened, right?
Cause every time we would come back
to town, more people would come.
And then more people and more people.
And in regards to seeing
the actual success, I mean,
even now that she's been gone for 22
years, I'm still baffled at the fact that,
hey, I'm here at Google. Hmm. You know,
when we're fixing to release
something amazing. Yeah.
And she's still being talked
about. Right. Awesome.
Um, so kind of, I think
part of your story,
obviously there's so much amazing
like positivity to it. Um,
but there's also kind of like, uh, the,
the part about hardships that you guys
definitely faced a lot and I think that's
part of the power of your story is like
overcoming that. Um, so we know that,
you know,
given the fact that you were
Mexican Americans in the
u s but then also that you
were,
this female led the Handel group,
which they kinda was like a male dominated
genre at the time. Yeah. It still is.
And you guys definitely did.
Baseau those things.
So what was it like when you
were in the thick of everything?
Like dealing with that
both because you know,
you're in a bicultural individual and this
and this, you know, in this country. Um,
but then also in, in this
genre that's like, so male
dominated. What was that like?
Um, definitely it was a very difficult
one because Celina was so young when we
started performing,
she started seeing when she was six and
a half and professionally when she was
like nine, nine and a
half. And so that made me,
we're about 14, we're four years
apart, so I'd maybe about 13,
14 and then my brother is four
years older than I am. And um,
you know, I guess we didn't,
when we first started,
we really didn't see it,
see it because we were so young.
And my father kind of shielded
us from that. And I grew up,
we grew up in Lake Jackson,
Texas, which was, you know,
I didn't know what a low rider
was until my ninth grade year.
So it was predominantly,
you know, Anglo people,
some black people,
but very,
not too much Hispanics going on.
So I really didn't understand a lot
of that until we started growing.
And then I could understand
more about, okay, uh,
this promoted doesn't think that we
can job because Salinas a girl, right.
Or work kids,
you know,
when we were kids back then got admit
that like the diamond should be a factor
because our music still
sounds good weather. You know,
it doesn't matter how old we
are or what, what, you know,
if Selena was a female or not.
Um,
I think my father dealt more with that
aspect of it and saw more and felt it
more.
But as we grew,
I will tell you that I
did fill it more and um,
you know,
and it's surprising to me that it's still
like that and we're 22 years later I
still see it and I still vibe it because,
you know,
I see what goes on in the
world. Right. You know,
and I see what goes on with other artists
and their difficulty and struggles and
definitely it is no matter what
people would like to say, you know,
it is this more of a struggle for a woman,
for female to make it in a male
dominated business than it is for,
for male. Right, right.
Well I will say that, um, you guys,
I think we can all agree
are like an inspiration for
a lot of those guys who are
dealing with that.
And no matter where you are,
I mean it applies to like
the music industry tick.
It applies to pretty much
every industry. Right. So, um,
I think that that's something that yeah,
that definitely a lot of people say
will tell you one thing that I think my
thought my father always told us,
you know,
cause we would get very discouraged
whenever promoters, you know,
didn't want to book us or have a set
of venue or things like that and,
or something didn't go right with
our record company or whatever.
My father always told us, you know,
oh, so you're just going to quit.
You just,
just like that you're going to quit
for everything you've worked hard for.
And he would just tell us all the time,
we need to just, um, you need to stand up,
brush off of your knees where
you fallen and try again. Right.
And that's always been our philosophy,
our philosophy fall off it.
Um, that's, that's
incredible words. Oh, well,
I mean going along those lines
of like male dominated, um,
kind of like worlds that females
definitely can hold their own in drawing.
You mentioned this earlier in the talk,
so droving professionally
is definitely still was,
it still isn't very male
dominated. Um, what was it like,
I mean you mentioned kind
of your first reaction to,
to it and when you were introduced to it,
but what was like throughout
your experience in the band?
Like what was your experience, um, in that
role? Um, especially also, like I said,
given that the condo music,
I mean,
just the fact that you were a girl drummer
and that kind of music was also like
a double whammy in a way. Um, did you
ever consider changing instruments?
Why or why not? So first kind of
what, how will the experience,
and then if you've ever thought like,
maybe I should do, first of all, no,
I cannot sing. I guess so much. I'd be
like, why don't you sing? I'm like, well,
there was a reason why.
Um, no, I mean, I grew up,
hello. You know, performing. I really
did. I, it grew on me. I initially,
I didn't like it.
You know,
you're talking about being put into a
position where you're like, wait a minute.
You know?
Um,
I loved it and I love the fact that
I was traveling with my family.
There's pros and cons to that. Yes,
we did argue, yes, there was that, ah,
you know, and certain things
that we've maybe disagreed with,
but at the end we always came together,
right.
No matter if you disagreed or agreed,
we always stuck to whatever, you know,
whatever the final say the United
States. It was whatever we did. Um,
I,
I really didn't find myself any different
to be honest with you. Performing as a,
you know, I'm the only really was the
only female, a drummer back then. Um,
genre of music.
And for those of you that don't
understand what the haunt of music, is it,
the magnitude of it,
the magnitude is about
the magnitude of Tahani
music and Latin music.
It's about that bit,
right? It is basically a,
um,
form of music that is performed in Texas
and only in Texas basically. Right.
Unless you are lived in Texas
and you moved to Chicago now.
So Chicago
really that big on a, on a spectrum of
this bed. I'm not in music. So you know,
I take pride in saying this, that we,
I'm having a genre of music, this bag,
we took that music and we
cross boundaries and it's not,
it's very difficult. And don't
ask me what the, how we did,
I don't know how we did
it, but it, we are music.
It didn't matter whether you're from
Puerto Rico or from whom are from me.
He pulled out matter what,
what nationality you were
our music appeal to everyone.
How I tell him,
I don't know. I think it was
a combination of clearly are
our music. We were, you know, were Mexican
or Mexican American, Mexican, like third,
fourth generation here.
I grew up on English music.
I didn't listen to Spanish music until
we actually started performing. Um,
it was a music that my father introduced
to us and we're like, oh, oh no, no,
no, that's not cool. That
is not like we were all in
against any, he's like,
no, this is your route.
You have to understand where this is
coming from, you know, blah, blah, blah.
And we grew to love it, you know? And um,
but you know,
it's just really,
I think it was a combination of the fact
that the fact that we were raised here
in the United States and we
listened to like men at work.
And then I was all about Janet Jackson
and Matana and you grabbed this,
what we listened to and then my brother,
you know,
fused what my father infused in us with,
with our culture.
And then that's how we created our sound.
And then adding the fact that
Selena was very soul foreign,
her singing and you can vibe that and
you can hear that when she's singing
Kumbaya,
you can really hear that soulful vibe
that comes from the music that we grew up
on.
So it kind of spills over.
Yeah.
Hybrid type of music that were created.
Definitely the right mix of everything.
So, um, I mean you talk about,
we talk about, um, you know, you created
your own thing, you, you, you know,
face a lot of obstacles and you
persevered. Um, specifically with Selena,
what do you feel like,
um, you know, you know,
obviously you're her sister and like
very close to her when you guys were kind
of out and doing it, like, was there,
was there something that you felt
like for her just like meant so much?
Like one obstacle that
she kind of, um, that she,
that thought through and
was like, wow, I like,
I'm really proud of myself for that.
Or like in my career,
that's an easy one.
That would be the English crossover that
she was working on before she passed.
I mean, that was something
that, um, you know,
if you're on this side of music
and mainstream is like a huge,
you know,
who doesn't want to go mainstream.
And so that was a thing that from the
get go, she wanted to be able to do,
we want it to be able to go
mainstream and to be able to,
to have a crossover album. And, um,
even though that that complete album
was completed because she was murdered,
you know, um, she's still
got to experience that.
And she cried when she found out that
she was actually, because it's, it's,
it's really a lengthy process
about picking up the correct song.
I remember they sent us
to La, um, uh, to shed,
had recorded an English song.
I can't think of the name of it right now,
but she recorded it and,
um,
they felt that her reading
technique wasn't correct. My do.
My sister's never had any type
of vocal lessons whatsoever.
So they felt that her breathing wasn't
right on the song. So they sent her to La.
I remember going with her.
I had a blast.
So we had a great time. Anyway, so
she went to go, um, with a
coach that did Michael Jackson,
all these famous singers.
She stayed with them a whole week.
He coached her. Um, she comes back,
she rerecorded the song and then the
executives heard it and they're like,
oh,
we like the original version better.
They ended up keeping it the way
that it was. It was, uh, oh my God,
I'll think about it and I'll
just blurt it in a minute,
but I don't remember
the name of it. But, um,
it's just a really lean out the process.
And I think that that was her main
goal was to be able to do the English
crossover. And when she actually was
finally able to do it and they said, yes,
we're doing it,
finally doing it.
Cause she'd been telling her fans for
like over what, three years it's coming,
it's coming. And then
it never did. And she,
she literally cried into
the wholesale bear hard,
which is well, who was the president
at the time of Emi records? He goes,
I promise my fans this. I
want this. I want it so bad.
And it ended up happening,
but unfortunately she didn't
get to finish doing it,
but she got at least to do some of it.
That's awesome.
Um,
well talking a little bit
more specifically about
Selena before we kind of get
into her legacy,
like what,
what would you say was like your
favorite thing about [inaudible] or like
something that you
really, really feel? Yeah,
come on. Everything. I know if you were
to pick one, I know there's so many,
but like if you had to pick
one thing or rather like,
I can tell you the one
thing. Yeah, go ahead.
One thing. My sister, of course,
all of you all know she had
this beautiful hardy laugh,
but she was extremely goofy and very,
she was wanting to always laugh at her
own jokes that she would never say a joke
like all the way through.
Correct.
And then see what lot herself.
I like
everything to be the only one really
laughing after everybody stopped laughing.
Yeah.
And it was Kinda like,
I guess that was the practice who was
such a fun person to be around and so
easygoing and, and just laughed
really about everything in life.
Even when she was upset about something,
she would just kind of blow it off.
I'm like, ah. And she would
crack a joke about it.
So I definitely say probably that was the
thing that I'm did I miss most. Right.
That's awesome. Um, so moving on
to kind of like a little bit of,
of of Salinas legacy,
obviously it's very clear for fans,
like even people, even like people were
very, very young today that, you know,
obviously you weren't alive
when, whenever she was, um,
she's a beacon of hope and inspiration
for bi cultural people all over the world.
Um,
when I guess like,
did you really feel that when you guys
were in the thick of everything and did
it feel,
did you feel a sense of pressure and
like responsibility because of that? Of,
of like, oh, like we're actually
like, people look up to us, Pete,
we're like a source of inspiration
for people. Like we kind of,
we felt like that's like a weight on our
shoulders or did you just kind of feel
like love and it was like
kind of like this fun? Yes,
Julie felt all love.
There was never this like
we like for instance,
when we played at these nasty don't, like
there was like our main goal was like,
God,
I hope people show up.
And then we found out that it
was sold out. Like it was like,
why don't we sold it out?
Like it was never,
there was never this
like thinking about that.
It was more about like our short
term goals, you know what I mean?
And just kind of like taking it like
that and never really thinking about what
we were doing, why we
were doing it. Right.
So I know some people plan their
lives, okay, the time I'm this age,
I'm going to do this. And you know,
they have certain goals that they want.
Our goal was just like,
dude,
let's just survive and get money and
have a house and a car and eat and we're
good. You know what I
mean? That was our goal.
It wasn't to be able to be this rock just,
Oh my God,
this phenomenal group or anything like
that or I hope we're inspiring people.
It wasn't that mindset for us. It was more
like, all right, let's go play. Right. Um,
many popular artists today,
obviously I think, you know,
like think of Selena as an inspiration
to them and you see them, you know,
like sharing photos of her
and like wearing her on
their clothes and things like
that. So how does, what does that mean
to you and your family to see that?
Like what kind of goes through your head?
Do y'all see the Drake?
It's recently,
oh, Diplo wearing a sleeveless
shirt too, right? Uh, it's, it,
it warms my heart. I mean, you know,
it's pretty incredible and it's very far
in between like what is happening right
now with her legacy and what's going on.
I mean,
we're in a different phase now and
I mean, I've, I've always seen it.
I get asked like,
how do you feel about this and do you see,
and did you see this coming? I
was like, well, yeah. I mean,
I remember when my sister passed away,
one of my goals,
my father's balls was tall.
He made it very clear.
You've wanted to make sure that
nobody forgot about Selena and I,
and we work very hard
behind the scenes on,
and we're very selective of things that
we do. Associate Celine, his name too.
Um, uh, and there's a reason
for that. You know, I,
we've been offered to do so many
crazy things and we just say, no,
that's not what we want to do. Like, no,
there's a reason for it. I think also,
you know, just, just having
her presence, you know,
and people knowing about who she
was and what she represented,
not just as a person,
but as far culture.
She is definitely a role
model for us. Latinos. Um,
she inspires the youth. Um, she, um,
was very much about not doing drugs.
She was all about, you know, um,
speaking out about, um, she was, uh, I
don't know if a lot of people know this,
but she was a spokesperson
for battered women.
She was about giving back
to our community that way.
She was very loving and she wanted just
to like everybody to kind of like, um,
understand where she was
coming from as a person.
And I think that everybody gets
that that's, that's ever hurt her.
And then not only that,
but I think that how can you not be
captivated by her 22 years later?
You look at her now,
she's still looks very current.
Selena was so what you would consider
an artist that's timeless, you know?
Um, you know, her look was very simple,
but she can kind of like cool,
right? But not over the top.
Yeah. People still like coffee or, right.
Oh, like if even if you sit down and just
block all that out and just listened to
her vocals. Right. You know, if
you listened to her, her, her,
her voice captivates you.
If you just listened to it,
it just captivates you and you know,
then on top of that,
just add the fact that
she had this amazing body
and she had this amazing
personality to go along with it.
So she, I hope that, you know,
another 20 years we're
still talking about her.
Right. I'm sure that will be the
case. I will definitely do my part.
She was definitely one of
the greats. I will say that.
And I can say that. I agree.
I agree. Um, so actually you just
started to mention this a little bit,
um,
among many other things.
So Lena was and is known for her style
and being a trendsetter. This is my note,
frankly, her performance
wardrobe, everything she
was fears and like on point.
But what was your style behind the scenes?
Was it different from like what
people would see and like what,
what did that entail?
Um,
tee shirt,
baggy jeans about her hair slicked
back in the load button and very,
very little bit of makeup.
She always wore makeup and just very
little and a little bit of lip gloss.
And that was her right?
Very stripped down.
Very like she used to also like to grab,
um,
Christmas shirts and she used
to just like, uh, like the,
the Umopar TV though video. Are y'all
familiar with her? She's wearing the red.
It's tight. That's Christmas shirt. She
had a big old suitcase full of stuff.
And what does she do?
Pull out?
So, um, the, there's also
another outfit she's wearing,
she's wearing all white and
it's one of Chris's starting.
She just like tied it and tucked it
under and just made it hers. Right.
Um, she was, um, when she
wasn't performing, um,
she was, you know, opening
up her boutiques and um,
she was actually working on her makeup
line. She was wanting to do a makeup line.
She was also looking into perfume.
She already had picked off the toes
of a perfume that she wanted to do.
So, um, she also was
attending a business, uh,
university and here in La
via correspondence, um,
for business because she wanted to educate
herself more on the business side for
her business, her businesses. So she
was, I have her on tape actually, uh,
went on a thesis. Nobody's
ever heard it. Really? Yeah.
It kind of sounds crazy
because he's talking like
that's smart. Well, I actually didn't
know that. That's incredible. Like,
I mean obviously she was,
I mean in the time like an entrepreneur
for sure and had that mindset.
So that's really cool to have it.
That that was something that like behind
the scene she was really pursuing, um,
kind of on a more traditional level
that she wanted to be a mother.
She was, um, you know, are in,
Chris wanted to have children. She
wanted to have like an army, but
Chris is like, Whoa, calm down.
Um, and she loved, you know, of course
animals and she wanted to have, yeah,
she didn't want to have
a farm. Wow. Crazy.
The Sky's the limit. Right? Yeah. Um, so,
so we talk about how Selena was,
I mean,
you guys were just an
inspiration to people and a hero.
A lot of people consider her like
a hero heard their, their heroine.
But who was hers? Do you feel like,
did she ever talk about someone who,
she really just looked up to
that my father and my father
and my mother. Okay. I mean,
my father played a huge role in and
guiding us. He's still guides us.
I mean, he still manages us. You
manage is my brother. He's a force,
you know, that we've
always looked up to. Um,
my mother has been always also somebody
that my sister's always looked up to
you. I would definitely say those two
poop or, or, or the ones that I still,
if you ask me that question, my answer
is the same too. Right? Yeah. My parents.
Well, I, I, um, agree.
My mom is awesome line.
So say it's funny how
that works. Right? Um,
I think the last one before we kind of
go into the doodle and we can open up for
questions for people. Um, you talked, you
mentioned a lot about like the movie you,
you were like the
anecdotes from the movie.
So how was it working on that project?
How accurate was it?
Was it because that's also
something that I've always wondered.
And what was it like to see yourself
and your family portrayed by actors?
Um,
well when they've,
we first talked when they first kind of
crazy how the movie came about once she
passed away,
um,
our lawyers in la found our entertainment
lawyers that found out that, you know,
somebody, there's already
companies wanting to make a
movie and because we live,
you know, there's freedom
of speech, anybody can kind
of basically do everything,
um, without giving the consent of the
family. So that's the only reason.
That was one of the main reasons why
the movie came out two years after she
passed,
because we,
if anything was going to be done and
we wanted to make sure that it was done
correctly and it was done,
um,
the right way and portrayed Selena in
the right light and not any other life
just to sell movie
tickets. Right. And, um,
so the whole process was,
it's pretty insane. Like what,
you know, the whole process of trying
to pick a Selena, you know, that,
uh, they narrowed it down out of
like, I don't know how many girls,
like seventies on girls to like five.
And Jennifer Lopez was one of them.
And actually the lady, uh, the
girl who paid Constance Marie,
the one who played my mom, she actually
oxo audition for the saline apart.
And so, um, you know,
they narrowed it down.
And this one girl, she wasn't a
professional actress. And, um,
I, my, I wasn't on the sat,
but they all did tapings like a live
tapings have thing like filming.
And uh,
this girl looked like my sister so much,
it was crazy. They dressed her up and I
was like, whoa. But she could not act.
And after like the 30 [inaudible] take,
you could hear all the,
like my dad said that you could hear
like everybody working, you know,
I mean like,
cause that right there is an indication
making it [inaudible] he wouldn't be
good to make a movie.
So then Jennifer came in and they just
thought that they all agreed or the
directors, executives and
everybody agreed and you know,
alongside with our family that Jennifer
was a perfect park for, you know,
for Selena,
you know.
But the crazy thing was with what
surprised us is that a lot of the,
like once they announced that
Jennifer was going to do it,
there was a lot of backlash from Selena,
from the fans because they're like,
oh my God, how can a Puerto Rican portray
and Mexican, you know, blah, blah, blah,
that way war. That freaked
me out because, you know, um,
the same here, you know, like in my head
I'm like, it doesn't matter. She's Latina,
you know,
and that's the important thing in the
fact that she's physically looks like my
sisters. I mean like bodywise, um,
the fact that she has dance, um, you know,
Jennifer has dance background. I
mean, um, I thought it was perfect.
Like we were, we were super happy once
everybody come down. I, everybody was,
but the whole process,
Jennifer worked her butt off.
She stayed with me for about a
month at my house. Um, there are,
we'll share a story with y'all.
She totally freaked me out.
Came in like,
you know,
after a while you do when you're
hanging out at somebody's house,
like you get comfortable or she
came downstairs and we were getting,
we were in the kitchen,
we were going to eat and we're
preparing food or whatever,
and then she comes and I have a
sectional and my sister would,
Jennifer came in and she sat right in
the middle where my sister would sit and
she brought her feet
up and she grabbed the,
I have like a little rap thing, you
know, like when you get cold, you know,
I don't know what to call her
throat. And she covered herself. Um,
never forget this. I looked at my
husband and he looked at me and I'm like,
my sister would do the same exact thing.
Wow.
Yeah. Take me out. And then
that, and we're cooking. And
I'm like, do you think she's
right?
It's like, do you think, but
how would she know? You know,
mean like something like that. It was
so cool to work with Constance addy.
Almost all of them. It's a lot of work to
do and moving. I just want to tell. No,
I think the, um, the sets of the house,
you know, where I'm cutting prices,
hair and all that, that was all
they, they created that they went in,
they took pictures of our house
and they read, we constructed it.
And the scene in the movie
with the bus where, you know,
I'm pissed off because of
the Dorito situation. Yeah.
Right.
Pretty interesting because they, they
created a bus and it wasn't really a bus.
It was like in a of studio area and have
like big old air tire things that to
give it that movement, it was
like on a bus. It was super cool.
Little things like that just, it was
really cool and it was very difficult to,
um, there was some times that I, you know,
clearly I wasn't there every day. Um,
it was also very difficult,
uh,
especially the scene where, um, you know,
the hospital scene at the end, I
completely, I showed up all like, hey,
and then they told me what he
knows. Like, okay, bye guys.
And I laughed and I just heard that it
just, everybody was in tears. You know,
and um, Jennifer and Jochin
the whole, the whole,
um,
the whole crew and everybody just said
that it was probably the most difficult
thing that they've ever had to do,
you know, because it felt so real.
But it will share on a good note,
we'll end this section on Jennifer when
she came out of the trailer with the
white dress where they're recreating
the scene where Celina won the grammy.
I ain't gonna lie.
That was probably the only
time that I truly freaked out.
Like I got chills all over my
body cause when she stepped out,
she's kind of scooted her little dress
down and she looked up and for a split
second I thought it was my sister, like
I like, and she goes, what do you think?
And I was like, Oh wow,
you look amazing. Like,
and then we were just kind of sit back
and I just stepped back with my father
and go, we were just
like freaking out. Right.
Well, it sounds like, uh, you said
it was a lot of work, but I know if,
if anyone out there, I've seen it
many, many times. It's a family game.
It's a family thing. Um, and I will
definitely see it one more time. Um,
and so it definitely, you can tell that
it was a labor of love than it does.
And I love that it's there because it's
something that not only for people who
loved her,
but it's just like a great way.
I'm so glad you guys had a hand in it
so you could tell the story the way you
wanted to tell it.
And it's just a great way for a lot of
people to learn about her story and I
think that it helps,
so it keeps losing his memory alive.
That's how a lot of,
I feel like a lot of millennials can
identify or understand who she was because
the movie's always on there.
Like they hear the music,
they start seeing what's
going on. Right. You know?
Right.
Well that's a perfect segue into another
thing that I will do a similar thing.
The Google doodle that we'll be
launching next week on October 17.
My last final question before I open it
up for people is kind of what kind of
went through your head, whatever, cause
I full disclosure gave Susan a call,
it was like, hey, we want to do this.
What's kind of the first thing they can
went through your mind and really Google
yes. There also like, yeah, you're like
to the community. Like this is great.
Um, but yeah, so like
kind of what was your,
what was your thought when
we first approached you and
how has the process been
free?
Um,
I was pleasantly surprised that
I got a call from me that a lot.
Um, I initially, you know that when
you and I started talking on the phone,
I instantly found this
connection with you. Um,
I could hear the passion that you had on
presenting what you guys want it to do
and it's all, it's been that
from day one, you know, um,
there is definitely passionate in this
creation that you guys are fixing to see.
Um, sat down with [inaudible].
I got to meet you and Kevin, um,
talked about details of certain
things and what your idea was.
And we kind of Torque it here and there.
And I think that the Google
wraps up Selena completely,
even though it's very short, it,
you know, in the sense of, you know,
it doesn't total, it's not like a
whole hour long curly, but it's,
it's perfect because
it sends a huge message that, you know,
you can do anything you really want.
Selena started when she was really young
and she became this amazing artist and,
and she's still being remembered.
And you know,
I will end up with this Salinas favorite
saying is the impossible is always
possible. And it is. And
I think that this Google,
there's that form of that totally in that,
because it shows the passion that
you guys put into it and, and,
and the whole creativity of,
of having her young
shine the story throughout to is.
Yeah. And we hope that everyone,
like I said,
both fans and people who don't know about
Selena will be able to learn about it.
Um, and along with it we're also
going to be, um, uh, launching, sorry,
at launching a digital exhibit of select
items from this. And I'm Louisiana.
So that's another collaboration,
amazing collaboration we have with the
Convenia family and we're excited for
people to see a lot of the
things there. Um, a lot of gray,
a lot of great iconic items.
Yes, definitely. I think the hardest
thing for me is, uh, you know,
you already know Latinos are
like really hard to keep secrets.
Come on.
They
were like,
why are you going to San Francisco?
Oh my,
what are you doing? I'm like,
I'll tell you later on the 17th,
because I'll give you a call. Um, cool.
Well we're going to open up for questions.
Hi. Thank you for being here. Um, yeah,
I was just wondering if there were any
things that you do for your sister just
to honor her memory that are personal
to you, that you're open to sharing.
I think when you lose someone,
like having, you know,
these special things are,
it really makes a big difference,
um, as a family. Um, from the get go,
from the first anniversary of
her that we have are passing,
we kinda just don't get together.
We don't make it a, an event. Clearly
it's a day that she lost her life.
Um, we just kinda like call
each other, Hey, hi. Hey,
just checking on you. Say any fear.
Okay. That's basically all we do. Um,
in regards to me, you know,
remembering her or anything like that.
I don't do anything special
like that. It's, um,
I just keep her here and in here and I'm
good and I just try to keep her always,
and even when I'm shopping,
it's crazy cause I'll be shopping and I'll
be with my mother and when we're like,
oh my God, that Selena like, oh my God,
she would totally buy this, you know,
stuff like that. So I keep her alive
like that and little things, you know,
throughout my day. This right here
is a total labor of love. This is,
this is one of the things
that brings me great joy. Um,
coming here and speaking about her
to you guys, it means a lot to me.
Um, you know, I,
I do this because I love her because I
know if the shoe was on the other foot
and I wasn't here, I know for a fact
that she would be here doing this for me,
you know, and, and so it's definitely
only real love. So, and that, and that.
Then going back to your answer, no,
I don't do anything in particular.
And then none of us do,
not even Chris,
we just kind of check on each other
and make sure we're good. And some,
it's crazy because some,
it has been 22 years and some
last year was really bad.
Some, you know, you just want to stay
in bed and crier but off, you know.
And then other days, I mean,
some years you just want to like,
you're okay and you want
to talk about or you just,
you don't have no problem and
then you want to blast the music.
There's some days that I don't even
want to hear our music cause it hurts.
It's just, um, I remember when I,
when she passed away some, this older man
of my, a friend of my father's told me,
you know, time with time, time
will heal your heart. And it,
I found out it doesn't heal
your heart, your, your, your,
there is a void there in your
heart that will be there for ever.
You can never feel that.
What time does,
it helps you deal with what's been put
in front of you and you have a choice to
either move forward or just stay where
you're at and you don't do any good and
staying where you're at. I learned
that because I went, you know,
I took about two and a half years
before I figured out me again.
That's how long it took me to
figure out who I was again. So,
but you do a lot I think.
I think the things that you do,
I mean just having gone and spent some
time with you guys in Corpus Christi,
which was like a really
awesome thing for me to do. Um,
just seeing like the museum and you know,
how,
how you treat the people who come there
that really want to learn about Selena
and cherish her memory is just
really awesome. I think like,
and just watching you guys do,
you know,
the day to day and all the calls and
like answering questions and all of those
things. I think all of those, all
the, you know, in your day to day,
I see you guys honoring her and making
sure that people who love her and people
who want to learn about her do
that. And I think that, um, yeah,
in that way it's like,
it's really awesome thing that I was able
to see in person can just go up. Yeah.
Okay.
So I had, oh, I had a quick
question from the back.
Um, so I mean, I think so working
with Prolo and this doodle and,
and the team has been amazing and getting
to meet you today is just fantastic.
Um,
but I think what surprised me is like,
I always knew that Selena was so popular,
but seeing how devoted her
fan basis through the, uh,
basically throughout this
project, um, like do,
like what is the fan
interaction like with you now?
Do you still get a lot of artwork
or things that people are, you know,
sharing with you and your family?
What does that like? It's awesome.
Pretty creative people.
Well,
send some pretty amazing
paintings on Selena.
I love interacting with
those Salinas fans. Um,
I like to hear stories
about, you know, um,
what Selena means to them, how she
inspires them, how they live up to her.
Um, I love hearing that. I mean it's,
it's amazing and it's a good feeling.
It definitely leaves that good feeling.
And you know, going back to like,
when you lose someone,
you know, people die.
People lose their loved ones all the time.
And I'm super blessed.
I tried to look at life like that.
I'm super blessed having to be
able to like hear my sister's boys.
I'm able to see her on youtube.
I mean,
I'm able to hear stories about how she
inspires people and that's part of the
legacy that is part of her legacy.
And I feel that,
you know,
I'm doing my part to help that along with
her fans because clearly we cannot do
this without her fans.
So I feel blessed. Cool.
Cool. Hey, thanks for coming. Thank
you for, I have two questions.
One is on behalf of my sisters,
they wanted to know what,
what was Salinas favorite shoe designer?
MMM,
I know.
I,
I don't think she had any, Selena
was one to just really shop anywhere.
Um,
she wasn't always like
about designer stuff.
Uh, she literally just,
if she found something,
I remember one time we were shopping and
this lady goes, oh, I like your dress.
She goes, thank you. I gotta at Kmart
Asleep. I was like, I knew she got it.
It came up by that.
My sister loves shopping. If it was
cool and she liked it, she bought it.
So she wasn't really in
the designer designer things back then.
Um, my knew she liked the good stuff, but
you know what girl doesn't cause she
didn't have any favorite favorite. Okay.
She wore a lot of boots
too when she performed.
So she would always look out for boots.
Perfect.
I'll tell him to keep it simple.
Oh, in the movie, uh, Edward James
Olmos so I think he's a fantastic actor.
Played your father as sort of a
very dominant machismo, a role.
I think Latinos across the country can
resonate that whether it's the mother or
the father. Yes. How was that
dynamic in a band group though,
when you know that that's your father,
but also your manager and how much
pushback did the kids give to make sure
things got done at the end of the day?
Um, at the beginning. I mean,
clearly, yes. Is that, first of all,
pretty much all,
all Latino's understanding
what you just said because yes,
there's that male machismo and that's
just the way our culture is. Um,
at the beginning, I think that's what
helped us, um, because it was pretty much,
hey, we're going to do this this way.
And as we started getting growing,
we started having more say about what and,
and actually that's how my brother
started producing our music because I'm a,
was complaining about, um,
complaining to my father that,
that the music that they
were sending us was,
and there were treating a be kind of like,
Eh, you know, kid, get away. You know,
other producers that were in our John or
music, they were like, ah, you know, um,
and Abe with getting really
frustrated. So my dad said, well,
you don't like it then do it yourself.
You know?
And that's how he became a producer.
That was him.
What I'm trying to say is that machismo
part of my father and that strip part of
him pushing us and pushing us
and pushing us. And one thing,
I think that was,
uh,
it didn't bother us because clearly
you were raised in that environment.
So I was like, okay, it's dad
being dad. Right. You know?
But now in hindsight,
I look back and I think what a blessing
because if he wouldn't have pushed us
and push us and, and never let us
like stop doing what we're doing,
then this wouldn't have
been, you know, and you know,
and it's so it's a blessing. And
um, yes was their arguments. Yeah,
there was arguments but we pretty much
were okay with things the way that there
were being handled, you know, um, eh, but
a little complaints but nothing on a like,
Kaboom type of thing, you
know, like a situation. We
pretty much were in agreement.
We're always like, okay, if you
feel that that's what we need to do.
Perfect example. Um, uh, when
we got signed to Capitol Emi,
which was our first major
album, which is what, uh,
the date of the doodle is
actually the front of the day,
the first September 17th, that is,
the doodle day is going to come out.
It's actually,
um,
celebrating our first album
release with capital Emr,
which is our record company.
That was our first big record company.
And when we were going to sign with emi,
we,
Sony was also interested in us and Sony
was offering us way more money to sign
versus emi. But my father
told my, my father was like,
no I don't. I don't think that's a good
idea. I think we need to stay with him.
W let's go with emi.
Were all through like going all
doing way more money and he's like,
it's not about the money.
It's the fact that emi doesn't,
this is a new thing for them,
a new venture and to Tahana music,
they don't have any artists right now.
It's like,
so that means that they're going to give
full force and whatever they do to make
sure that whoever is signed with them,
they're going to back them
and make sure that they,
they go where they need to go.
So it was more of a business decision
that we took and so we allowed,
we stepped back and we said,
all right, we'll check,
we'll let you do your thing and thank
goodness because it was probably the best
decision that we could have ever made.
Thank you. And your teachers are fresh.
Awesome.
Hi Susan. Hi, my name is Cynthia. It's
nice to meet you. Hi, first of all,
I just wanted to say I live in Salinas
and anytime anybody ever asked me who my
favorite artists of all time, it's,
I always say Selena, thank you.
And of course my question is,
uh,
what is your favorite Selena Song?
And do you know which one was
Salinas favorite to perform?
Good question. She used to love for, for
me it was still good. God, I don't know.
Still the God cover tunes. Um,
I don't know.
She used to her favorite
English or or whatever.
I don't know about performing
at the top of my head.
I really can't say as regards
of what her favorite was,
but her favorite song was a
bike stream more than words.
That was her all time favorite to the
point where we would tell him to shut up
in the bus.
She would sing it over and over and over.
We tell it to go to the back of the bus
because she would shut up about that
stupid song. Right. Um, my
off time frame it is, um,
uh, you'll flee out gay, uh, or, uh,
a lot of it on the chat as a normally get
mosque clearly a bit more than I'm 10.
I was like [inaudible] he has, you
know, stuff like that now to me,
all of them are amazing.
I never listened to our music back then,
but I tell you what,
when I lost her,
that's all I listen to and I actually
carry our music in my car because I didn't
do that before. Like, people would be
like, Hey, give me when you see these.
I'm like, you're kidding.
I don't have mine.
You know what? A cassette tape. I'm sorry.
So, um, I don't know. That's a good
question. I don't know what Celine,
his favorite song was. Hmm. That's
good. Thanks. Yeah, I think the one,
what is the one that she used to
like tell him the guy off his,
he really got into it kicking
a, yes, that's a good one.
Remember when she's like singing
it to the guy? She gets down,
it's grabbed it like she called somebody
out from the audience. There's video.
Very should call somebody
out and she went to,
she invites a guy and when she tells him
you're going to be my boyfriend and the
guy gets don't have.
Yeah.
Huh.
Hi. Hey, thanks for coming.
Um, so obviously you spoke a
little bit about it and uh,
how,
uh,
this was like a family endeavor getting
into the band and doing this together,
but I was just wondering like what
were your own personal like musical
inspirations back then in also
like what are you listening to now?
MMM,
back then I really,
you know,
back then it was all about Joe Jackson
and Madonna men at work, you know, uh,
pretty much what every other kid who
was into in like the what the 80s.
Oh my God. It sound cool. But yeah,
and in regards to now, I mean,
I pretty much listened to like everything
that's in the radio, Bruno Mars. I like,
I'll let you know. I like
drag. I like, you know, um,
Charles Scott. I mean, I listen
to a little bit of everything.
One thing I didn't listen to back then,
which I was like, Eh, was country music,
which is weird cause I'm from Texas.
But um,
I really didn't listen to country music,
but I find myself gravitating more toward,
towards it now as I'm a little older, but
I listened to everything. You name it,
I'll listen to it. I have no set
preference in regards to like,
you know, the whole music
musician aspect of it. Um,
you know,
I think growing up and being
mmm
self taught because I learned how to play
the drums from my dad with his weird,
I guess he does not a drummer and also
like a friend of mine that was a drummer
in our cut my cousin as well.
Just getting the basics down.
I never learned how to play, uh, as
a musician. Are you a musician? Yeah.
Are you dumber? Okay. Well Jennifer
is, they have to play with their wrist.
I tended to play,
I taught myself because I was self taught.
I play more with my forearm
than I do with my wrist.
So my roles are no as fast as
what they should be. Um, but,
um, one thing I do say that, am I a
fancy drummer? No, but I tell you what,
I am a solid.
Yeah,
that's what I've been told me. I can
keep a beat. And that's one thing
that's really cool about our
music too was that we never,
like there was never a fight with
one of my brother produced our music.
There was like,
you know,
sometimes you get a like a whole bunch
of musicians together and everybody wants
to take the lead and Glam
boolean and all that stuff.
We kept it pretty much simple and clean
and I think that that also is another
reason why our music still resonates
22 years later with a lot of people.
It's the drummer.
Cool. I think we have maybe even Tracy
at one more time for one more question.
No.
Hi. Um, thank you for being
here. I just want to share too,
building on what perilous said,
but I remember seeing, um,
I was really little when Selena passed
away. I was, I think I was like 10. Um,
and I had heard a music,
but I didn't really understand your
story until I saw the movie and I was in
junior high and it was like the first
time I saw a Latino woman in such like a
leading role. And it was really
just incredible for me to see,
um,
my culture,
my mother's culture being represented
in such a positive way and,
and like a stage that you know, that
the world sees and he just, it just,
you know, it's stuck with
me forever to this day. Um,
so I thank you guys for like wanting to
make sure that the world continued to
know her story. Even people who weren't,
you know, obviously there at the time,
it's like being able to have shared
that and continuing to share it today.
It's just, it's just so incredible for
the entire, um, the entire world really.
Okay. But my question
for you is, um, you know,
what is exciting you musically these
days or what, do you have any, uh,
personal, uh, music plans as the drummer,
a yourself that is on the horizon or,
or that you could share?
Well, uh, first of all, thank you for your
words. I almost cry right now. Seriously.
They're very hard phone.
I appreciate that. Um,
I don't have any plans right
now. I, I stepped out of that.
I didn't, when Selena passed away, like
I said, I took me about two and a half,
three years to find myself again. And, um,
I didn't find the need to play
anymore to be honest with you. Um,
my brother continued with his band,
you know, going to be kings. Um,
he created a band that's
been very successful. Um,
but I just didn't find myself being
okay with playing with anyone.
Um,
I didn't want to start my own band.
I didn't feel like, I don't know, I
just, it was just didn't feel right.
And then I just kind of
gravitated into, um, you know,
we have a production company that
protects, our production company,
has three recording studios
and we have like we do,
we have our editing department and
we have a graphic designer now,
so we do layouts for cds and DVDs
for other bands and things like that.
So I just kind of found myself helping
my father and just so many people calling
and doing things and I don't know,
it just kinda like felt
right just to be there.
And so now I am CEO and president of our
company and I wear a lot of different
hats and um, well I ever
play again. I played, um,
we have a yearly festival and Corpus
Christi called Fiesta though a flawed and
our city.
Um,
I got up and I jammed with my brother and
Jackie Cruz from the orange is the new
black. She was down visiting for that.
We had our seeing like get there.
And it was, and it wasn't planned.
Literally my brother's like, hey,
you want to play with me tomorrow? And
I'm like, what? And I haven't played. Um,
I was so freaking nervous.
You have no idea.
Like it was insane.
It was probably the coolest insane.
I felt panicky.
I didn't remember the count of our song.
Like I had a couple of drinks
[inaudible]
but it was crazy because as soon as I,
soon as that second or third became in,
it was like riding a bike.
It was like, oh, I got it.
[inaudible]
oh Lord. And um, I don't
know. I don't know what,
what the future holds. I don't know.
Like we'll ever play again. I don't know.
I'm one of those and I'm very spontaneous
and not like if I feel like it may be
when I get a little older.
Yeah. Maybe. Why not? I mean,
not that I'm, I'm very old,
but one thing that I will say that was
really cool about that night was that, um,
I have a son,
he's 19 and he got to see me plex.
How cool am I?
Right. So, um, I dunno.
Maybe, maybe one day. Cool.
Well, thank you, Tracy.
Tricky question. Um,
and thank you guys again for coming and
thank you to Suzette and your family.
Thinking, I mean, this was like
a dream project for me. And,
um,
obviously like just a super meaningful
for a lot of people at Google and on
October 17,
hopefully it will be extremely
meaningful to a lot of people out in the
world as well. I love it. I
love it. I love it. This is
just, this is just another,
um, another thing that just elevates
Celine and just kind of helps us.
So thank you so much and
thank you to Google for,
for coming to our family and wanting
to do this to honor her and, and uh,
I think that her fans, you guys are
going to make so many people happy.
It's going to go crazy. I'll just, yeah,
I know. I'm so ready to break
the Internet. I just want to do,
I didn't just want to tell somebody
right now that'll, that'll come soon,
but thanks so much and thank you.